i try to sever myself a little bit from
that problem because i know this kid
just made a major mistake you don't go
to another family that was a mistake
so at this point
michael sends two guys to come see me
two guys that i know very very well made
men or no uh one's a maid guy one is a
associate associate yeah
big guy though
so i meet them at a restaurant right
next to my office they call me and when
they called me i said who is this and
they uh said it's heckle and jekyll or
whatever stupid name they used so they
said we're next door at the restaurant
come see us so i go there and there's a
vestibule there
and in the vest of you we don't actually
go in the restaurant and one of them
says listen you guys are doing an ipo
that ipo has got to come here it's got
to beat us i said well the ipo is not
going to you it's going to johnny he
said you can't do that i said listen to
me johnny's writing me letters he's
calling my house he's telling me i got
to be strong he's only as strong as his
friends are on the street i can't give
you this
he said well this is going to be a
problem so i said well i don't know what
you want to do you want to roll around
right here in the vestibule you're not
getting it i don't know what you want to
do but you're not getting it
that night i go to a club in uh bay
ridge brooklyn
michael's at the bar and i went there
specifically to see maybe he'd be around
i was going to approach him but i knew
he'd approach me
so he sends one of the guys that i saw
in a vestibule over to see me and he
says mike won't stop you so i see
michael at the bar this is 1996 and he
said you're crazy man you go see my two
thugs like that my goons and you tell
them what you told you don't need to see
anybody else you're with me you just see
me
like you think this guy johnny could
help you this is leonardo this is okay
number one he's old number two he's not
well liked number three is a drunk
number four when he comes home he's
moving to florida he can't do anything
who's the time of moving to florida
johnny
johnny yeah
so now i got a skipper
telling me i'm directly with him
so i got to make a decision
how much more loyalty can i continue to
support johnny g with now that michael
himself is telling me this so i'm going
to guys that i respect their opinion
wise guys what do i do everybody's
saying you don't understand michael he's
going to be a boss one day you're in
great shape this guy's going to be a
boss you're doing the right thing but
now technically i'm betraying gamorano
which i'm very uncomfortable about am i
willing to die over it i don't maybe i
mean i love the life i wanted to be part
of his life this was made for me and i
didn't want to answer to anybody so i
had very lofty goals i didn't want to be
a skipper i want to be boss
you i mean again you can though you're
half sicilian you're not a hundred
percent right
you have to be 100 italian
i thought you used to be 100 sicilian
back in the days
okay so you have to percent italian it
doesn't matter for yourself don't even
have to be 100 italian your father has
to be italian
they changed it though it used to be the
mother could pretty much be anything and
your father has to be attacked
at the time okay so you're okay so i
thought it was 100 sicilian my point is
i don't take orders very well but i'm
going to be in this i want to run it
were you really ambitious enough to one
day want to be a boss or no
if it was there for the taking yes i
would have okay because i i think i
understand the biggest mistake the mob
ever made the biggest mistake ever
besides the fact that there's no loyalty
and there's just
they made such a mess of it
the problem is if they ever ever
really implemented and this is supposed
to be organized crime i mean look how
organized it was with my alaska and
lucky luciano so you know everybody says
when gotti came it's because paul was a
businessman paul was a businessman he
didn't know the street first of all of
course paul knew the straight he was
indicted it did time for hijacking so
don't say he wasn't a straight guy maybe
you know he forgot those routes and he
became a businessman but that's exactly
what was needed without a doubt a
businessman not nobody was flipping at
the time how do you explain that so what
happened is now with the new regime
nobody's providing for these families so
if patrick is going to go away for sal
that sal better do the right thing for
patrick's family and with nobody doing
that and nobody implementing that and
instilling those values and you're left
for the philistines why would you stay
loyal why why would you
so you understand merita was impossible
in my world this and i'm gonna use the
word conformity a lot
if are you familiar with joe valachi of
course okay so joe vellante lets he was
the first rat sure but what joe village
did is he gave mario puzo and francis
ford coppola the platform to understand
a world they never would have understood
and because of all that information out
there from velocity now puzzle's able to
write a book
so once francis ford coppola comes into
this mix and he's such a family-oriented
guy he brings the family element into
organized crime in the mafia and what
happens is everybody wants to be part of
this so the the wise guys may have not
acted yeah the way
the way marlon brando acted now they
wanted to act that way so you want to
talk about art imitating life or life
imitating heart there's the reason so
now you have a whole new spectrum of
what this is supposed to be about but
everybody forgets this patrick so let me
remind you of something there was no
federal presence there was no fed
investigation
as early as 1960 you have j edgar hoover
stating publicly there's no such thing
as them
so if you're relegated to local cops you
keep them on the payroll you stay off
the radar it was pretty easy then once
rudy starts bringing in you know
the ricoh act and now you have that he
changed the game though without it
before him bobby kennedy really did too
because now all of a sudden there was an
attack on the mob
and the only reason in my world why
bobby kennedy ever went after the mob
was to keep it quiet about how his
brother became president there's a lot
of different speculations there there's
a lot of different speculations there
because of all
situations they were worried about
illinois with dewey they needed those
seven thousand votes from dead people
west virginia they really didn't need
illinois by the way that was going to
happen without it and then they hated
the fact that there was that uh uo was a
favorite type of mentality and bobby had
the bigger ego than john apparently
uh but at the same time there's a little
bit of link with the marilyn monroe and
women and sonny there's a lot of
different stories to it but but the
point is once the attack on the mafia
started now
and it's publicity now and it's
publicity nobody needed it and joe
bonanno's book also didn't help by the
way he wrote that book that joe colombo
with his italian civil rights campaign
and then of course john in 1985 so what
shot did this have so if it's going to
be an imminent prison sentence for
everybody provide for the families do
you think guys are flipping because
they're afraid of jail these guys these
are men
nobody's afraid of jail they were afraid
of not providing for their family so if
you and that was one of mikey scars
concerns as well when he talked about in
the interview with trevor mcdonald he
says i called the guys i'm like wait a
minute i need food for my wife for my
wife and the boss said
get her on uh welfare because she needs
to get on so let me get her on welfare i
can't get around welfare and then that's
when he flipped he showed that in good
fellows too yeah so the concern is if
you can't support your family the person
is going to flip
well that's just one you know part of it
did you follow tommaso boshetta's story
as well or no
similar story there as well slightly
different there because of uh
you know the point is a wise guy takes
an oath to put this okay closer yeah
ahead of god in their own family i mean
only an imbecile would actually do that
you may make that profession at your
induction ceremony but do you think
anybody really believes that do you want
to put this thing closer ahead of your
child ahead of your god
i mean where's that gonna get you so
it's a fake statement to begin with but
my point is if they ever implemented
something to provide for the families
and how would they have to be a formula
you know based on your contributions
earnings based on where you are still
somebody still would have flipped though
without a doubt yeah but my point is it
would have been less i think it would
have been contained no it would have
been less okay so now you you get with
mikey scars they tell you he's going to
be the boss he's a couple at that time
you're going in is this still 99 when
you're netting 30 or what year is this
with mikey's 96. so now it's 97 and the
fbi comes to my house knocks on the door
six o'clock in the morning there's two
agents there and they tell me i'm gonna
be assassinated they tell me there's a
contract on my life and it's coming from
the west side which is the genovese
family so i said can you tell me why and
they were like we don't know anything
about you
we just obligated to tell you this from
informants there's contract on your life
from the west side i said and you can't
tell me anything he said supposedly some
stock deal that went bad so i said well
i'm not involved in stocks so i don't
even know what you're talking about they
said look we're just giving you the
heads up
so obviously i took this as a credible
threat so in my mind i believe this is
gamarano
from prison god plotting to kill me
knowing he can't use the gambino family
to kill me so he had to go to the west
side that's what i believe now
so now i have a choice do i sit inside
like a hermit do i change my lifestyle i
didn't even move into my new house yet
and i only had i had two children they
were babies and i'm still on parole i
got a probation officer an answer to so
now i call her and i tell her i guess
i'm obligated to tell you this but the
fbi just left here telling me i'm going
to be killed she said well if you have
any problems you know my number i'm
licensed to carry a firearm great
so now i'm left saying what do i do now
so obviously i go to michael i explained
to him what's going on
and i said would you think i was crazy
if i told you i think it was gamorano he
says no i wouldn't think you're crazy i
think you're very very smart you've come
a long way in these last few years
and we were left to believe that so yeah
i guess this is when i started realizing
you know i don't want to say how tough i
am but yeah at the end of the day i
wasn't going to change anything i made
the decision that this is my life that i
am in this i'll do what i can to protect
myself i have my crew i'll do whatever i
can but i'm not going to change anything
and again i hadn't even moved into my
home yet i hadn't even bought the new
brokerage firm that i was going to buy
and this was just really at the start
so we got off we did deal after deal i
did all of these other businesses things
were going very very well
and then pete gotti gets pinched in
2002 at some point
and then at my restaurant we're having a
birthday party for michael i want to say
that was june 2002
after michael left his party he arrived
home and i think at five o'clock in the
morning that morning he got picked up
and pinched
so now he was arrested too
so now ironically enough at the time
where michael
is now in jail gamorano is now back on
the street
so where do you think that leaves me and
this is where everybody betrays me
i get bounced around from guy to guy
nothing but issues nothing but problems
9 11 happened the internet bubble in
march of 2000 happen things are no
longer robust and good and now
camarado's playing his games and now
this is when everything goes bad and
then ultimately in may of 2003 is when i
agreed to flip so if you like this sort
of short clip from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]